it's time for The Adventures of Indiana
Jim this has been the adventures of
Indiana Jim
[Music]
hello everyone I am Walter Binet dziak
I'm Heather roofs and I'm Anna Wade and
this is top five most of us love Indiana
Jones across four great movies there are
tons of amazing moments in this
franchise
well three great movies the Indiana
Jones character and films are beyond
legendary at this point starting in 1981
with Raiders of the Lost Ark Indy and
the creators behind him like George
Lucas and Steven Spielberg have given us
one of if not the most iconic
action-adventure series in cinematic
history
with a proposed fifth film still in
development Indies greatest days are
most likely behind him but that doesn't
mean we can't celebrate his greatest
feats on screen anytime we want there
are scenes and sequences that will
always be close to our hearts and today
we cover the best of them these are the
top 5 best Indiana Jones movie moments
number 5
not only is it movie trivia worthy but
also my personal favorite moment of the
series in Raiders of the Lost Ark
Indiana Jones is being chased through a
market with Marion when she is abducted
by Nazis he's cornered by one of the bad
guys and in perhaps the most baller
Indiana Jones move he takes care of the
baddie in the most logical way shooting
him eliminating any need for a showdown
for those who don't know this iconic
scene has an interesting backstory the
original scene was supposed to be an
extended combat sequence of sword versus
whip it was going to take a few days to
shoot unfortunately Harrison Ford had
intestinal distress on location and was
constantly returning to his trailer
making longer sequences difficult to
shoot Harrison remarked that it would
make more sense to just shoot the
swordsman and that's exactly what he did
yes the stunt guy learned an entire
sequence just to have it cut at a
moment's notice this moment was so
classic indeed that I had a callback in
the sequel Temple of Doom Indiana Jones
reaches for his gun
finds an empty holster and must finally
fight the swordsman gunless number 4
I don't think the sequence is talked
about quite as much as it used to be
which is a shame because it's incredible
in Temple of Doom Indy Willie and
shortround are on the run and trying to
escape the temple by jumping into a
minecart they're quickly followed and an
epic chase ensues through the monstrous
caverns unstable tracks and high speeds
make for one bumpy ride this isn't
really just one moment the whole scene
needs to be praised and appreciated it's
one of the best pure effects sequences
I've ever seen and it more than holds up
now the expert use of miniatures mixed
with the full-size sets
flowed together perfectly even the water
rushing through at the end looks
realistic since that was shot with the
miniatures to avoid seeing the water
droplets the effects team used air
cannons to keep the water looking as
unwieldy and wild as possible this is a
true cinematic achievement and while I
don't think it's talked about as much as
say the trench run in the original Star
Wars it's absolutely on that same level
now there is some early blue screen use
that doesn't look great upon close
inspection but if you're into the movie
that's barely noticeable quite simply
they don't make them like this anymore
nowadays this would be any throw away
heavily computer animated sequence and
there would be nothing unique about it
at all what makes it stand out is the
craftsmanship and by hand hard work put
in to make it look as realistic as
possible I've never seen it up on the
big screen but this would probably be
ten times better in a theater however I
have written the Indiana Jones ride at
Disneyland and it's one of my favorite
the park close enough I guess I
encourage you to look up some
behind-the-scenes videos about the
making of Temple of Doom and this scene
in particular it's fascinating to listen
to the effects team talked about how
this sequence was done number three
[Music]
few images and scenes are more
iconically Indiana Jones than switching
an idol out for a bag of sand and being
chased by a giant boulder this was a
part of the opening scene of Raiders of
the Lost Ark the opening sequence as a
whole is arguably one of the best
openings to a movie it is the perfect
introduction to the character and the
world of Indiana Jones
we are dropped into the climax of a
typical Indiana Jones caper as Indy
begins to explore the temple the
audience is able to see the skill and
knowledge with which he conducts himself
to eventually get to the idol in the
final room of the temple he then
attempts to disarm the final trap using
a bag of sand that he collected at the
entrance of the temple the first time I
saw this scene I remember holding my
breath as Indy switches the idol with
the sand for a moment we think that he's
done it then the trap is triggered and
the temple begins to fall apart the
music picks up the editing becomes more
frantic our hero is put in life-or-death
situations here we see that India is
also resourceful and can make up a great
plan on the fly the final element of
this chase is a giant boulder that
indeed narrowly avoids as he jumps out
of the temple so many elements came
together to make the scene wonderful the
music the shots the editing the
practical effects character moments
people have been trying to imitate it
for decades and continue to reference it
even in current pop culture number two
this moment might make you lose your
head but don't have a meltdown
the whole of the first movie had been
building to this moment the Ark of the
Covenant had been found but it was in
Nazi hands fearful that the Ark was a
fake the team of Nazis and archeologists
perform a ritual to open it before
taking it back to Germany during all of
this Indiana Jones and Marion have been
captured they actually play a very small
role in this scene and have their eyes
closed throughout to avoid the awesome
power of the ark the ark is opened and
lightning strikes out at the Nazis they
are then surrounded by an ethereal light
that turns deadly
leading to an infamous death scene totes
face literally melts off like there is
so much power or radiation or whatever
coming out of the Ark it causes his skin
to liquidate and stream off of his skull
besides being amazingly gruesome it was
the perfect payoff to the build-up of
opening the ark the effects look great
and do a wonderful job portraying the
action the effect was created by first
taking a face cast of the actor the
artist then built a skull made of stone
and layered gelatin with other bits like
yarn to create the melting face the
final result took many attempts before
the perfect formula was found it was an
innovative and amazing practical effect
one of the things that takes it to the
next level though is the gurgling noise
at the end so creepy but so amazing to
many dimension almost every major moment
from the first three films could fit
here so if you want to see some more
best moments from the series go ahead
and rewatch rate at the last arc Temple
of Doom and the Last Crusade it's time
for more adventures with Indiana Jim
[Music]
and the number one best Indiana Jones
movie moment if you chose boy to me
this scene defines Indiana Jones our
hero has reached the Holy Grail literal
but Walter Donovan and Elsa Schneider
are there to ruin the party among many
false Grails the true cup of Christ sits
but Elsa purposely gives Donovan the
wrong one killing it
now Indy has to find the real Grail to
save his dying father it's everything I
love about these movies all in one
sequence the stakes are high with Henry
Jones senior bleeding to death from
Donovan's gunshot and II just made it
past the trials and booby traps we get
another twist on the face melting scene
and of course we get one of my favorite
characters in this whole series the
Grail Knight
the Grail cannot possibly on the great
that's the bundle price of immortality
the presentation of this character was
fantastic and I think Robert Edison did
an amazing job in the role it almost
makes me want an animated spin-off
series like they used to do back in the
day the misadventures of the Grail night
featuring Indiana Jones it could be
about the night integrating into 1930
society I would have watched the crap
out of that and that wave it's the best
in cinematic history his line delivery
is also legendary you who have chosen
Indy finding the true Grail and saving
his dad was great as well actually
anything with Indy and his dad was great
Indiana Indiana
[Music]
let it come
I love this scene so much I love the
Last Crusade
I love Indiana Jones it was mostly a lot
of fun rewatching these films they're
like nothing else except the serials
they were based on I guess but they will
always be a gold standard when it comes
to adventure movies and one bad
installment can never change that make
sure you guys check out my new show fan
scription in it we theorized how things
would have played out if big events in
film history took a different turn in
our first episode we asked what if
Apollo Creed survived his fight with
Ivan Drago in rocky for that episode is
up now right here on channel awesome
also speaking of Indiana Jones type
adventure movies you guys remember
Vernon Wells from commando Mad Max - the
road warrior and Power Rangers time
forest well I'm in a movie with him yes
really and yes that's my real hair it's
called City of Gold and it will be
available on Amazon Hulu iTunes Google
Play and more on Tuesday December 4th
with a DVD release on January 1st 2019
if you're in the UK the movie is already
out under the title the lost city of
gold
I have an interview up with a director
of the film over on my personal channel
now so check that out for more
information or go straight to city of
gold the movie dot-com to pre-order we
want to hear what you guys think what's
your favorite Indiana Jones movie moment
what do you want to see us cover next on
the show leave a comment and let us know
to keep in touch you could like my
Facebook page or follow along on Twitter
on Facebook Twitter Instagram or
subscribe to my animated movie review
series right here on YouTube then you
can find me on Instagram Twitter or
twitch or I stream on Wednesday nights
well catch you right back here next week
with the worst Indiana Jones movie
moments on a brand-new episode top five
[Music]
[Applause]
you